le retour des samouraïs rien que ça
l'événement organisé par l'us orléans
loiret à mélanger les genres proposera
au public un spectacle son et lumière en
même temps qu'un événement sportif
on a pu aussi découvrir des techniques
telles que le duo système enchaînement
esthétique de combinaisons d'attaqué et
de défense
denis brogniart célèbre animateur de koh
lanta présenter la soirée le dj dessus
c'est c'est considère un peu comme le
parent pauvre
ce sont des gens qui sont beaucoup moins
connu il n'y a pas de jeux olympiques
donc forcément pour des sports amateurs
comme ceux ci c'est important qu'ils
aient une soirée aussi exceptionnelle
que celle du palais des sports
le public ensuite eu droit aux combats
entre les champions oriane est la
meilleure nation monde l'allemagne
combattre s'ils sont soldés par la
victoire de l'us orléans 3 contre 2 avec
deux victoires côté femmes et une autre
pour percy compte sa mascotte du club
orléanais
c'était une très belle rencontre est de
faire ça avec mes copains du club qui
sont aussi mes collègues en équipe de
france c'est quelque chose de génial
et puis pour les clubs c'est un très bel
événement le fait que ce soit à domicile
qui est ce public derrière nous j'ai pu
j'ai réussi à rester concentré et à
revenir très vite au score et a bien
mené ce combat
côté allemand romane apollo nov champion
du monde 2014 a battu le relais année
julien mathieu 10 à 2 même s'il ne
combattait pas à domicile lui aussi
gardera un souvenir exceptionnel de
l'ambiance hier soir chadha normes il
n'avait jamais encore avec une telle
ambiance et un spectacle si grandiose
je vais regarder ça en tête elle raconté
à mes enfants
2500 personnes dans le public ont montré
une fidélité sans faille au champion
orléanais et se sont évidemment réjoui
des résultats
ils ont été supérieurs
notion particulière si les enfants sont
fans et moi aussi j'aime beaucoup
franchement magnifique s'enrichissent
énorme je m'attendais vraiment à des
combats est lourd parce que en face
l'allemagne c'est vraiment une équipe
géniale aussi mais ce soir ils ont
vraiment assuré
franchement merci à eux et c'était
génial l' us orléans réfléchit déjà au
prochain show qu'il organisera en 2017